ir le parlement européen a ratifié le
traité de libre échange entre l'union
européenne et le vietnam un texte qui
doit supprimer pratiquement tous les
tarifs douaniers entre hanoi et
bruxelles d'ici dix ans presque 70 ong
ont alerté sur la situation des droits
humains au vietnam et sur son coût
écologique également signé à la fin du
mois de juin dernier à hanoi l'accord
pourrait entrer en vigueur dès cet été
et réactions tout de suite sur twitter
pour manque emmanuel macron tient son
conseil de défense écologique
ces eurodéputés votent le traité libre
échange et au vietnam
quel cynisme les échanges maritimes vont
s'intensifier avec un des pires pays en
matière de déforestation pollution
plastique gestion de la pêche traité de
libre échange ue vietnam
l'acte ii écologique de macron commence
décidément bien mal le green deal
n'est-il qu'un greenwashing
institutionnalisée épisode numéro un le
parlement européens votent
majoritairement pour l'accord de
commerce du vietnam
pourtant contraire à la résolution green
deal voté il ya un mois les députés pro
macron voté pour contre l'avis des ong
alors que le parlement européen a
décrété l'état d'urgence climatique
il valide un nouvel accord de
libre-échange climaticides retrouver
notre communiqué de presse en réaction
au vote scandale du traité de
libre-échange eu le vietnam